hey 42 here today I want to tell you a
strange and terrifying story and by the
end of this video you will gain a
fascinating insight into the psychology
of a tiger that will change how you view
this majestic animal forever
did you know viagra is the Sanskrit word
for tiger I'm sure there's a joke in
there somewhere but it's an appropriate
name because like the famous male
enhancement pill a tiger should never be
underestimated when it comes to
dangerous animal attacks you'll usually
find a predictable possum sometimes a
person is stalked but mostly they're
attacked it random in perhaps a fleeting
moment of territorial aggression or fear
but what you will never find is when an
animal specifically hunts one man in
order to kill him
that is extraordinarily rare and is what
makes this story so unique because there
is one instance when an amour tiger did
exactly that and what happened will
astonish you now fair warning the
following story is true but disturbing
it's 1997 prime Oya Far East Russia is a
place where man and nature exist in
their own unique relationship and have
unspoken rules bordering with China
Primorye aswer over 600 miles of forest
wilderness beset by steaming hot summers
that swore with unforgiving books and
harsh frozen winters it was here during
one of these frozen winters that a young
desperate hunter named vladimir markov
was hunting in the forest when he
stumbled across the mutilated corpse of
a wild boar it was immediately obvious
that the boar had been killed by a large
powerful animal potentially a bear or
leopard but most likely
or tiger the incredible violence of the
kill suggested as much but scanning the
tall grasses around him there was no
Tiger to be seen stealing the kill was
an unmissable opportunity for markov he
was starving after all and much of the
ball could be sold and eaten this meant
sparing him the cold and potentially a
days wasted labor without finding game
so he decided to steal it even if it
meant a confrontation with a tiger this
fateful decision would be his undoing
but perhaps this confrontation was
exactly what Markov wanted or at least
he thought he did like most animals
conflict between man and tiger are
almost always the result of an unhealthy
environment where food and opportunity
on both sides are scarce Tigers begin to
view humans as direct competition and in
the case of this killing that's exactly
what happened
Pramila is a region long beset with
poverty unemployment and poor pay to
hunters in these circumstances
Tigers are attractive game at 10
trillion dollars the global black market
is one of the world's fastest-growing
economies and after drugs and weapons
poaching is one of the most popular
black market trades in traditional
Chinese medicine almost every aspect of
the tiger is illegally harvested for
supposed medicinal value and at the
Russia China border Tigers fetch a fifty
thousand dollar price tag a tempting
amount especially for a starving hunter
even students of conservation have been
known to turn their knowledge towards
poaching out of desperation but the more
Tigers aren't like other targets of
poaching for one thing they are by far
the largest big cat on the planet where
in African lion or Indian Tiger can
reach sizes of four hundred pounds and a
more Tiger can reach six hundred
sometimes even meet you 1,000 pounds
but this fearsome size isn't actually
what makes the amore Tiger so dangerous
it's their psychology having grown up
along sind mankind as the rival predator
on land
vo more Tiger is unique in its
characteristics and confidence where a
lion will flee from Masai tribesman or a
leopard will always ensure it is out of
sight and a more Tiger is an apex
predator with a clear preference for
taking on the most dangerous animals
without hesitation it is an animal that
devours Russian bears in their own caves
will charge helicopters attempting to
track it leap out of the water onto
boats far out at sea horrifying the
fishermen on board and it will even in
some circumstances hunt and kill the
animal all over creatures fear mam
a hungry a moor tiger is like a honey
badger on crack it doesn't give a
but unlike a honey badger it has to
skill strength and speed to back up its
enormous bollocks it's no wonder that
many Primorye locals call them more
Tigers the Czar of the forest a fitting
title for an animal that treats itself
as such and if in the case of vladimir
markov you've now offended the tsar by
stealing his kill he will most certainly
come after you
to put you in your place which is
exactly what happened after tracking
markov and it's borer that had been
stolen from it an enormous tiger
exploded from the forest after a
horrified Markov in a panic he threw the
ball to the ground desperately opened
fire onto the tiger and escaped with his
life into the forest but little did he
know the confrontation was far from over
Tigers are exceptional detectives with a
determined singular focus because it was
shot at close range the tiger was easily
able to identify the scent of who shot
it and triangulating which way its
attacker had even fled starting to track
Markov down
no human tracker could replicate the
skill of this
incredible creature to have it skill
stolen was a transgression but this man
had gone a step further and dared to
attack it the tiger would fire him and
kill this man and find him it did
returning to his cabin Markov spent a
sleepless night in terror he knew and
the depths of his soul that he was in
danger
and that by the laws of the premiere
forest he had committed a grave sin to
many of the natives and a more Tiger is
almost a deity it is said that if it is
watching you you would never know it
they say a tiger can see you 100 times
before you see it once that it can pass
through the long grass with only the
faintest rustle and as a single twig
broken under its paws but it is also
said that if you attempt to kill a tiger
and you let it live your death is
guaranteed and death had found its way
to Markov outside his cabin the tiger
had found him and in doing so patiently
began to study him to enter its preys
enveloped a concept coined by an
Estonian psychologist called jakob von
hooks cook and unveiled is the bubble
world that every animal lives inside
what he perceives
once needs what his habits are who he is
if you can put yourself inside that
enveloped you can better understand the
animal or in the Tigers case you can
better understand your prey and when
would be the most lethal moment to
strike the moment when he was most
vulnerable in the morning Markov rose
and nervously checked the outside of his
cabin to his horror everything with his
scent on it had been destroyed in an
eerily methodical way almost like an
omen
whatever this Tiger was it clearly could
not contain its hatred for him
I can only imagine how frightened Markov
must have been at this point at this
moment he could have packed up his
things and left but instead he decided
to confront the animal spike it's
amongst the trees ten metres from his
window Markoff raised his rifle and
fired on the animal wounding it terribly
and causing it to flee once it did he
took his chance and escaped down the
valley to where he knew a friend was
staying but little did he know his
decisions who wounds to tiger had
already sealed his fate his friends
didn't give him the reaction he expected
frightened his friend told him to stay
away that he had made a mistake that he
didn't want mark of anywhere near him
after all he didn't want mark of scent
or footprints bringing the beast to his
door he had his own loved ones to think
of he was well aware of the enormous
power and amour tiger wielded and
rightly feared it he also knew Markov
had brought this upon himself dejected
Markov sought out help from security at
the local sawmill telling them that he
had an encounter with a tiger and it was
now after him sympathetic they told him
to be careful but beyond that couldn't
and wouldn't offer any help poor and
overburdened themselves they weren't
about to risk their lives against such a
deadly hunter so Markov was alone and he
had nowhere to go
and the tiger was after him with the
cold winter night setting in markov had
no choice but to return to his cabin or
die he could even confront the animal
that he knew was waiting for him or
freeze to death in the snow he chose his
cabin and alone walked back towards his
final confrontation
a man that has offended a tiger of the
natives believe will most certainly die
and in this cold darkness the tiger was
waiting for him rather than impulsively
acting out in a spur-of-the-moment
aggression the tiger had set its mind on
killing Markov slowly savoring the hunt
and anticipating the kill and for almost
48 hours after their initial
confrontation it held no other fought in
its mind like a trained assassin the
tiger knew Markov would return to his
nest and it waited patiently until cold
tired and afraid he finally returned
armed and ready for the confrontation
Markov came back prepared for what he
must have known was his last chance to
survive the animal and whilst it may
have been easier to just fall asleep and
succumb to hypothermia Markov was no
coward driven by desperation into a
terrible circumstance he would now meet
his fate it was a few days later when
markoff's body was found his friend
Alexander de varnak was among the group
that found his body he was so horrified
by what he saw that not only did he have
nightmares ever since he vowed to
exterminate Tigers for not day forth
alongside the varnak experts were called
in to investigate the situation
inspection tiger an official unit set up
to handle conflicts between men and
tigers arrived on the scene led by a man
named Yuri trush a professional hunter
and conservationist
it was his dog that alerted the men to
the Tigers nearby presence invisible to
them it was apparent that the dog was
perturbed by the knowledge of the giant
predator it had detected in the darkness
none of the men could see the animal but
all of them could hear it as if it was
everywhere at once
trotty recorded much of the
investigation on camera he discovered
that Markov had been walking home when
the tiger found him
he found that Markos remains had been
dragged into the forest before they
arrived as they followed the tracks they
continued to hear the tiger nearby but
still couldn't see it at last they found
what had horrified Alexander de vorlix
so much the corpse at markov had been
mauled torn eaten and strewn across a 5
metre square patch there were limbs a
head but no body to be found the tiger
hadn't just killed Markov it hadn't
Radek ated him from the face of the
earth devouring the mutilating him over
the course of three days in an active
prolonged and cruel vengeance but to
truss there was something else that
disturbed him the tracks at the kill
site measured 17 centimeters suggesting
that the maneater that had hunted Markov
was an enormous fully grown male more
than 600 pounds in weight and over 10
feet in length trush could not imagine a
more dangerous predator but for now with
Markov's death they thought it was over
however they were wrong soon the paw
prints of a large tiger were seen around
the nearby villages lurking closer
stalking Holmes engaging in all the
behaviors that trush knew meant one
thing and one thing only
this tiger wasn't finished hunting men
and was now actively seeking them out
but for what purpose
everyone was warned to stay out at the
forest because a maneater
was lurking and coming across it meant
almost certain death but one man and
rape a chap Nia who had just returned
from the army ignored these warnings an
ambitious young man who was full of life
he wanted to roam explore the forest and
hunt likely choking up the official
warnings to scare mongering or paranoia
his death was reported soon later when
the inspection Targhee unit discovered
his remains there was nothing left of
his
body every inch of it must have been
eaten all that remain of perch apnea was
his clothing all of which had been
disturbingly removed and set into a neat
pile as if the tiger had carefully
undressed its victim like husking an ear
of corn
only the bloody stains told the obvious
story this new attack led the inspection
Tiger unit to make a final decision the
tiger had to be found and killed before
it struck again its last known location
had been a hunter's cabin that it had
broken into it had trashed a house and
lying on a mattress had waited for an
unsuspecting victim to return so it
could kill it thankfully nobody did so
it moved on the Tiger tracks indicated
it was limping on free pause where a
healthier more Tiger can move over 100
kilometers in a single day this one had
been lying down to rest every 80 meters
it's right for like had been badly
wounded presumably by Markov if this was
true then there was no way that the
animal could hunt its usual hoofed prey
which would now be far too quick for it
it's only option for survival was to
stalk slow unwitting men with this news
everyone hunkered down in the village as
inspection Tiger tracked the tiger
through the forest eventually coming to
an open field once there it became
immediately obvious that the final
meeting between the two hunters had
occurred Chaucer's dog became instantly
nervous agitated and then afraid it knew
what the men could not the tiger was
there and it was getting ready to strike
suddenly an enormous roar burst out from
around the map shaking them to their
bones and the tiger exploded from the
tall grass directly at your etroesch
each of the men startled then opened
fire on the animal the tiger Fluit rush
as he shot crushing him to the ground
with its enormous vicious
badi certain he was dead trust drove his
rifle deep into the Tiger's mouth and
pulled the trigger but when he came to
the tiger was dead and he had survived
the Tiger's Claw would have shred
through his bone lungs and chest but
instead it had lodged into his mounted
walkie-talkie miraculously that had
saved him and with the tiger dead the
nightmare was over helping trust to his
feats the inspection tiger unit began
their autopsy examining the animal's
body for wounds and skinning it to
examine the pelt in fine detail the
autopsy and skin confirmed Chaucer's
suspicions the animal had been wounded
many times in particular by bullets and
homemade bird shots that had ravaged and
weakened its body so much so that it
could no longer hunt wild boar
Sika deer or red deer and it had been
forced into continued conflict with man
it had decided to track stalk and kill
vladimir Markov out of revenge for
violating the rules of the forest if it
had never been shot or robbed of its
kill perhaps his whole situation would
have never occurred but it had continued
to hunt men of necessity they had stolen
its ability to hunt anything else and
survive and now his crush no doubt for
to himself they had stolen its life and
so ended the story of the maneater that
terrorized primordia but as the harsh
conditions of life in the Far East
continued to force men to take desperate
measures and the Tigers natural habitat
and prey continues to diminish one thing
is certain map an Tiger will meet again
if this story interests you then be sure
to check out John valence amazing book
the tiger linked in the description you
can also support a more tiger
conservation by donating to the relevant
charities and conservation efforts
because losing these beautiful creatures
would be an his star
Rick tragedy thanks for watching do you
enjoyed this video then please consider
supporting me on patreon it really helps
me to continue to make these videos the
links in the description also I've
recently launched my first book sticky
flight in it a thousand years of bizarre
history from britain and beyond you can
get your hands on a first edition signed
copy by heading on over to unban
publishing the links in the description
i'm pledge today thank you